with 329 kilos And then the best known is
Iñaki Pirena who has 320 then there is
another Hispanic team and has 300 kilos
Well it is probably a
small fin weighing 60 kilos But well at
16 years old he had already lifted 106 kilos or he
is going to do 18  this year and Well
there are several types of stones there are
rectangular cubes cylinder ball Those are
the official ones that are for the
championships and then we have the
baldarras which are the irregular ones that
are stones from Monte de Río stone
lifting is not only
strength it consists of lifting  a
stone at a certain time in front
of a judge you have to lift it up to the
shoulder, of course, if the judge does not give you a nullity
and the one who lifts the most times is the
winner, then it is not strength. Well,
here in sport, what do we do? They
take it between sport and  between culture and
coming Well, all the requirements that are
done here that are different, we
only do stone lifting
but there are many such as cutting logs and
such and all this comes from the work of
many years ago and well in my family It
is already with my daughter  It is the third generation
that is around and more or less it will have been
federated as a sport for almost 100 years.
I was inspired by my father, he played
this sport a lot. Well, my daughter saw me
and she also has photos of her grandfather and
such and I was going to take the demonstrations and  I
was there, I saw him almost every day,
both training and in the squares in the
photos, and in the end, since I saw him so much, I said well,
me too, well, that's what I
told my father one day that
I wanted to start lifting stones, he
made me a vest and some stones that  They were made
of wood and I started to practice
the technique a little and to this day,
here I am
and for two or three years the thing about girls is new, let's say
the last three years have taken a peak
for me in this sport, the
most important thing  In my case, it is to make visible
to both women and
young people that you do not have to have a physique that is
nothing out of this world to be able to lift
stones because although it is an
aggressive male sport, it is not like that at all,
in the end for me it is a
quite important position when leaving when going out to
the square, well, knowing that there are
boys and girls
looking at me saying I want to be like her,
so for me in the end it has been a
joy not to see more girls in the square
for me it has also been
easing the way
for me.  It is very important to me to continue with
this sport and the groups
in those active places. Because for me it is
the great part of our culture. It
is already something that comes in the family. For me, those of us
who practice this sport
carry the Basque country deep within us
[Music  ]
[Applause]
[Music]